well the CV Starr east asian library at
the columbia university and i'm very
happy we have so many people and come
over here under the very busy holiday
schedules and we have a lot of people i
know they have to go to second meetings
and the second party so we're gonna
start right now our first speaker will
be and these daunting vice provost and
university library thank you on behalf
of the columbia university libraries i
thank you for coming tonight to this
celebration today we establish the zoo
and shunt song education and culture
endowment fund supported by a chinese
entrepreneur mr. Chen su and his wife
Megan song the endowment will support
the collection development library
administration and other cultural and
educationally related endeavors of the
star east asian library one of the crown
jewels of columbia university in 1901 a
donation of twelve thousand dollars by
dean lung a chinese domestic employee
working in the home of one of Columbia's
trustees triggered the creation of the
Chinese Studies program the first
Chinese Studies endowed professorship
the Dean lung professor of chinese
studies that endowed professorship plus
the establishment of the chinese studies
collection through the donation of over
five thousand volumes of a chinese
encyclopedia by the Chinese government
in 1902 formed the foundation of today's
world class East Asian collection at the
star east asian library within the
greatest academic research library
system in the world after almost 115
years in the same spirit of Dean lung
mr. and mrs. sue have established the
shoe and song education and cultural
endowment and have made an important
contribution to improve the educational
and cultural exchange between the u.s.
and east
asian countries in deep appreciation of
their contribution please join me in a
few moments to unveil the recognition
plaque that is installed in this
magnificent reading room which is the
first such plaque dedicated to a chinese
donor couple in this library's history
big ideas like columbia global apply
well to the collections at the store
east asian library the magnificent
collections and the expert staff led by
the outstanding gem cheng benefit
scholars and students not only locally
at Columbia but globally throughout the
world it is truly an excellent library
and mr. and mrs. Xu your generous gift
makes it even more excellent also i want
to thank mr. frank shell president of
the US China friendship canceled and his
assistant miss Tang Zell for introducing
mr. and mrs. Xu to us we deeply
appreciate your making such a great
match let me also express thanks to
Professor Haru shirani chair of the
department of east asian languages and
cultures professor Eugenia lien director
of the Weatherhead East Asian Institute
and professor zhang wei for taking time
for their from their extremely busy
schedules to join me and give their
remarks for this important event finally
I would like to thank culture counselor
Lian Li and cultural console ping wang
from the office of the Consul General of
the People's Republic of China and New
York who made a special effort to join
us for this momentous occasion thank you
very much
our next speaker will be the professor
Howard Shore and each chair of the East
Asian language in the cultures this is
really great moment and we really want
to thank mr. Shue and his wife for this
very generous gift Xuanzong education
and cultural endowment fund it's really
thanks to people like you that we have
such a great library I'm just going to
speak about two things the relationship
of our department which is the
department of east asian languages and
cultures to cv starr a library we are in
the same building where the this is a
fourth floor I'm never quite sure where
this fourth floor or not but no this is
the third floor you can see I'm not
always sure we're on the fourth fifth
and sixth floor so we're very very
fortunate being the same building the
east asian library used to be in law
library which is of come up in the plaza
you'll see that looks kind of like a
little presidential building and we were
in the upper floor in a very very small
space and the i believe was to chair the
department at the time 300 Barry ah so
it was very very small space and the
department was together with the library
believe it or not so the professor's
were sitting on amidst the books and
Stanford University made an offer to Ted
Theodore de berry and to Donald keen so
the most prominent person in Japanese
literature and most prominent person at
the time Chinese Studies and so they
Stanford was going to raid Columbia of
their two stars and tend to Barry asked
as the counteroffer that he'd be given
can't haul this entire building had been
as a law school so you can see here it's
really not East Asian it's European and
believe it or not the department was
given a room in this in Kent hall and
also it led to the beginning of the east
asian library so this is a great moment
the other thing I would mention is that
the department has been great supporter
of the library on we've been generous I
think with our contributions out our
most recent one was thirty-three
thousand dollars for Korean painting
restoration for cream painting our
department has 25 full fact full-time
faculty in East Tibet China Korea Japan
and Tibet and another over thirty
lectures and over 100 graduate students
is a very large department or very we
work very closely with the library and
without the library I don't think we
need here and Donald keen whom I
mentioned earlier as part of the counter
offer has been a great donor
the library and has every year have
given both books in large funds and I
just can't stress enough how important
our benefactors are we this one of the
great libraries in the Western
Hemisphere both for rare books and for
the kind of range of material that we
have and we have a great director in
jinjiang I'm so glad that he's here and
so I want to thank you again very much
for your generosity we really appreciate
it very much thanks professor oh and our
next speaker will be that Eugene yelling
professor for Chinese history and the
director of the weather head east asian
institute
I'm also here to express my gratitude
and thanks to mr. and mrs. G for their
incredible generosity and their vision
for supporting the study of Chinese
culture and East Asian culture with
really such an invaluable gift and I'll
talk a little bit more about why it's so
meaningful for me as a Chinese historian
but also Chinese American who has long
been curious about my heritage but
perhaps first I wanted to just briefly
talk as the director of the East Asian
Institute the weather head east asian
institute is works closely with the
library it also works very closely with
the Department of east asian languages
and cultures in supporting the study of
China and East Asia throughout the
campus and we house faculty who are in
the East Asian language and cultures
department but we also house faculty who
study Chinese law in the law school who
studied Chinese business in the business
school who studied Japanese politics in
the political science department so we
bring together all the people who are
very interested in East Asia on campus
through programming and through faculty
support and part of our mission is to
support the library because I think as
we all know we're all academics we are
all scholars we're committed to deep
knowledge and integral to that of course
the cornerstone of that is the library
and so your gift is is really impacting
faculty but also our students and I
think that's something I want to stress
as well I think this is an increasingly
cosmopolitan student population on
campus students are no longer just
Americans we actually have probably the
growing population of international
students my guess is China and I'm not
for sure about that but what I find
really fascinating fascinating when the
Chinese students show up in my class or
when they come to the library is that
while they do have deep knowledge I
think they read the same books that the
Americans
let's do but sometimes from a different
viewpoint and I think the fact that they
can all get together and share their
different ideas and their different
visions and understandings of the world
is actually a great learning experience
for the entire student community it's a
great learning experience certainly for
me as a teacher and I think your gift is
going a long way to help attract the
best and the brightest students from
China from the u.s. from around the
world to participate in this very
important dialogue about the 21st
century the world we live in I want to
briefly say again my thanks to Jim who
has been a wonderful director of the
library in in terms of really ensuring
that we have the best quality
benefactors who are really committed to
education into East Asia and the weather
heads commitment to supporting the
library we have a long-standing
collaboration and we're always excited
especially Jim does wonderful exhibits
cultural exhibits and cultural events
and we're always very excited to support
those but of course we also support kind
of the nuts and bolts of running a
library acquisition collection the stuff
that's actually crucial for this
world-class quality institution to
survive and weather had wants to
continue that collaborative relationship
and finally again just to end on a
personal note I am born and raised in
the United States as a chinese-american
my parents immigrated here in probably
in the early gosh 60s first from China
and then to Taiwan and I've always grown
up a very much aware of my cultural
identity and when I went to college this
was very important I was at Stanford
University as a chinese-american that
phrase was very new I didn't know what
that meant but I think the kind of
awareness even as a chinese-american of
China only continues to grow among those
who have a similar background to me and
and as I said we live in a global
village the 21st century is a smaller
world and
we want to ensure that the Chinese
students who come here and then the
American students who come here and the
Asian Americans who come to columbia are
really responsible cosmopolitan citizens
and a gift like yours really makes that
possible so thank you very much our next
speaker will be do family professor of
Chinese cultures professor some way
sorry um so what welcome everybody on it
is my great pleasure to join you today
in celebrating the establishment of the
students own and education and culture
and down in the fund at the storage
station library but this is a special
occasion for us today we all know how
important this library is for everyone
here today right now so faculty we
depend on it in teaching and research
right this is the core of our support
life support system right as we all know
it takes years to build excellent book
collection like this one it started with
the beginning of the last century and it
also requires constant effort on our
part to maintain and enhance it okay um
as individuals become a go right and but
the library was stay it will continue to
stay here you know someone has Columbia
continually existent and prosperous
right so I want to thank mr. she and
Miss soon on behalf of my colleagues and
my students and also on behalf of the
future scholars and students who is sure
will communal continue to benefit as we
do from your generous support for the
library well this is my first time
meeting our donors mr. and mr. song but
I can tell that the we belong to the
same generation and we went to culture
you know when to college after the
Cultural Revolution and so I when I look
back I think our generation share some
common experiences and perhaps also we
share kind of a hunger for books that
developed in the dark days of a cultural
revolution we you know a lot of books
were officially banned and we learn
literally nothing at the school
we have the self-taught you know reading
books and ourselves and and perhaps of
even we share this kind of bizarre
experience of transcribing books
manually because that's the only way to
keep a copy of the books that you know
we borrowed from our friends we have to
return on time I remember copied cup of
these books and even make copy video
transcribed books are for my friends as
well so so the this is kind of a labor
of love now we can hardly even imagine
doing all this right also with your
generous support and under dr. change
the leadership I'm confident that our
library which is already in great shape
will continue to thrive finally I want
to thank on our donors mr. Sheehan and
Miss own for your vision and your
commitment to the well-being of our
library and I know that words are not
enough to repay your kindness and
generosity so on dr. china i decide to
present you with a book as a small gift
here is the
this is a photocopy of the addition of
the 16th century book are illustrated
the primer of a Ming Dynasty from the
real book collection of the star east
asian library are so she good asalu city
the conclusion to cover there are only
two editions that knowledge that this is
the earliest one and the other one is in
Taiwan in the palace museum collection
okay and I wrote a long preface to the
book to explain you know the to trace
its history and explain its significance
and actually this book has something to
do with the history of the East Asian
Studies here at the Columbia our
professor Goodrich how who once serves a
department chair at the Columbia I think
in 50s and 60s right ah he was the one
who refer to this book you know one of
his articles and he also provided in
English classes of to the other words
included in this book so according to
him this book is arguably the oldest
illustrated primer in existence not only
in China for the in the world okay so I
guess it's not it's good to have a copy
of it all right
that's the single copy in the word the
earliest illustrated lending books you
know from China and our next speaker
will be the guest of our guest of honor
mr. Ching shoot and also with his
translator miss salting so
Sanjan de colombia dashi future water
Kotaku's grant under and Aneesa tseng
chien de Jong go to new way to ninja hot
engine linea Telsa chancer pumping yes
sir sanjeeda god ah Tong Yahoo Yahoo
Hoshi to ram whose urban ren zhiqiang
jaja so herro ciao sanjana coda to
muriendo so swollen amici e essa San
jinda to search our Tongan Hodgins which
also sang de Chasseur sanjana carotenuto
swag wanza sanjay java san gennaro a
jabbing yamaha yama ginger Freeley hong
kong machine de l'argent animal my
goddess who she coded own yacht was open
season joe valachi teen tranny cheney
tambien achiever you so dear was
proposed and university librarian is
enthroned 10 dear mr. Li Li Yin the
Chinese consulate general New York and
dear professors from East Asia Institute
of Columbia University and dear mr.
champion the director of CV Starr east
asian library Columbia University ladies
and gentlemen good evening today my wife
monkeying and I are very honored to
invite you to attend the reception for
the establishment of the shoe and sewn
education and culture exchange endowment
fund and Evelyn and recognization plug
at universe at Columbia University and
to business is at east asian library
God ardougne otros agua y otro face on
yo yo yo honey I by donation Sammy
Gandhi sounds diga eaten want was away
means me Mendoza Graham yes hm a tratar
de tania to swansea east asian library
of columbia university has a very long
history founded a hundred years ago
before it was called East Asia library
and it was the first lab rate that named
as Chinese library in United States Tony
otros agua es una vita mia this range
and a yang yo-yo cheerio song gandi song
she determined attends a JA Jaso gender
don't know those honey otogi with so it
is one the largest East Asian libraries
around the country and the Columbia East
Asia library has been committed to
research historical documents and
academic exchanges during the past
hundreds of years in China's history
many famous politicians and academic
figures have left their footprints here
to Aden bucci each of those only Joey
kundo patch in peace and the Cheney tofu
mission cartoon called a job you see it
my mom devoted her whole life for
education her value and experience
really inspired my wife and I so I so
humble Indonesia wha-hoo fallen souljah
nice hansa yoga Shingen shivanand I well
muah javi of ambien so 10 years old ng
decision so it really wished that come
to monsey and eyes heart very very long
time ago that mangy and I really wish
to make a little contribution in culture
and education third uhren ha sinisa hey
when me Jim Buddha to me about zone
sequatchie saw a change in the ephod and
Tony puffin go Jada because in our mind
culture and education is a sign of
civilization and the progress of human
society it is important factor in the
development of international community
to Zoe were you are foreign come from
standing trading Jensen tranny coda she
saw hiv-1 watching it's G 10 mondongo
hueco de tania true Subban say Tanya van
ha zhengzhou you Father Son EG tight to
me niangua de Joie wen hua ji oh ha
jolly of a mere go to the away border
come share and there should have no
boundaries in culture and education
exchanges so together with my wife we
made this donation today to fund she and
so education and culture exchange
endowment pound hope that we can provide
more on research and development of East
Asia culture field of the East Asia
library at Columbia University as well
as to make some effort to the us-china
culture exchange and friendship
development for you are fallen then you
go da g un ty God are identical she can
defeat on the long machine it's all tied
sir oh ho foolin actually yes I've made
this life
that's all why you are foreign fees
honking gonna be a dashi jee gah
dah dah miata wait woman 440 gonna tell
you got pinned hi just as we saw this is
Miss so munching the wife and mr. xu
jing munching and I are very grateful to
have you to be here and thanks again for
Columbia University and a Columbia East
Asia library provides as such a great
platform for us to do some contribution
to the culture and education careers
organizational needs a home God our way
woman that jen jen Ching Lee Sunni yo yo
tambien genome and more Dada know me and
it's really great honor that columbia
university had made a recognition plaque
and to put it inside the library to
recognize this donation and we are very
honorable this tulisa that's the way
i'll cover the guy she may go to me you
harshly show invasions so she thought he
knew so well meant 80 g jean de tourney
change and our job and we want to
express our special thanks to mr. Sharif
a the executive president of China
American Friendship Association which is
him here and also miss jockeying the
general secretary of this organization
who is me for making this donation
happen that way she was doing what I
knee and shin our cecee now I create I
gotta asking sheesh ye jo of
vanilla
and uh Mary shooting said if he was like
20 years old younger so he can went to
the Columbia University for learning
some English so that he may not need
translators someday this is many many
young people the trimmed truly become
too young student 3 couldn't be our
University hey ho tai chi gong xi don't
go to Olivia to ninglin can shake away
jabbing kozhikode Chancellor actually
based on my knowledge is the little bit
edition that mr. Shue's English is very
good actually so our other and he
expressed his leg poor to the counselor
from intonations and from the New York
Chinese consulate and all of the friends
that come here to learn to witness this
happened today thank you again thank you
very much that's all next ceremonial the
thing is for a and the mr. XI to unveil
the plate back there
thank you so much thank you so much